all right hey what's going on it's bill
burn it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and I am just checking
in on you I didn't yell this time I
didn't yell at this time because I'm
sitting across from a man who is
currently setting the Guinness Book of
World Records for podcasting in a day
promoting his new show on Netflix stand
up in a way for episodes debuting
Christmas Eve ladies and gentlemen one
of the greatest of comedians I've ever
seen in my life
please welcome mr. Brian Regan bill how
are you man I'm excellent how are you
dude you you look like you're about
ready to glaze over here right there on
the whole media tour right did they go
did you do some morning TV did you do
that good morning TV yeah I'm not
comfortable with those morning shows I
tend to love doing these with other
comedians okay good good you know when
it's when it's not another comedian it's
I'm I am so hard to find your funny
brown boy it's what can people expect
from your show that the mote like if I'm
doing a phone interview like a radio and
phone radio interviewer as soon as I say
what can people expect people for people
who aren't familiar with them what can
they expect from your show I know right
away they're not familiar well yeah the
person asked me the question yes and I
just want to hang up like I just want to
get a few to be over at that moment is
your show gonna be the exact same thing
I just watched on television yeah that's
another one did you write any new
material now it's gonna be the exact
same [ __ ] the after I finally got a
special I then wanted to ruin it by
boring people by doing the exact same
stuff Brian in this company asked you
all hackie questions in this current
comedy climate how do you find the
altitude to fly yet with your current
presentation of satire another [ __ ]
critic it's a it's an insane world it's
in the same world right now but uh
anyways tell me about your show it's a
hybrid half stand up half sketch a lot
of the older bits that I used to do
years ago
when I do my shows around the country
people at the end of my show sometimes
like to hear some of the older stuff and
I'm like well what can I do maybe I
could do something with this so yeah you
know just think you guys you get you
like that good that you have like
classic jokes oh wow that's harder than
a classic song yeah I'm not gonna use
that word on myself but yeah nice of you
to say that but you know so I'm gonna
lay it on thick be the Johnny Cash yeah
well it feels good that people still
like to you know hear some of these
routines and I thought well maybe I can
do something with them but I don't want
to just do the stand-up I mean people
right I know that so I thought maybe if
I do like a stand-up bit and then that
segues into some sketch or something
like that and Jerry Seinfeld got
involved oh hey he was the one who
reached out and he's always been cool
with me and said that he wanted to help
spearhead me having a show I mean what
better phone call is that it says life
that's a big phone call you know late
like you you're on the phone going I
look at these goosebumps yeah yeah you
know it's funny when you said this when
you were describing your shows like
that's he's the first person I thought I
was like Jerry would like this show he
was so you know what was cool he said
that he had this idea he didn't have the
idea he said he wanted me to have a show
he said let's get together sometime and
see if we can talk about this and I was
like God and you know of course you know
and he was performing in Las Vegas where
I live so I went to go meet him at his
suite they have Suites and hotels that
are like that I didn't know we're
possible
pianos and you know so I go we go meet
and we chat and he said yeah you know he
thought that I was one of the comedian's
that hat should have a show which was
just a huge honor even hearing that and
he said well you know maybe we'll get
together and talk about it sometime
and I said well I have an idea and he
goes uh okay and I I know he likes
coffee my so I said you mind if we order
some coffee and we chat about it so
called room service they brought up a
pot of coffee I pitched it to him in
about three minutes you know and he does
not like it let's do it and I got
emotional I swear to God I started like
I got a tear in my eye because the show
business doesn't work like doesn't say
but his show business does yes exactly I
knew when he says like yeah yeah let's
do it and then you do it you know we I
knew it was happening that's always I
mean I'm belittling all the work he does
but like he has like the whatever that
is like he knows when an idea is good
and then he goes let's just do it and
then he does it he doesn't way he wants
to do it everybody responds and then and
I knew in fact that Bank truck up
exactly well I mean that the money part
isn't even that important to me you know
I mean right now but just his cloud
agent just slapped his forehead
there goes renegotiations way to still
be down to earth Brian at some point
could you be a little bit of a diva but
I knew when he said he wanted to do it
that it was going to happen right who's
gonna say no to him
you know and I knew that he's the one
shepherding this so anyway it was like
really cool that that he's supporting
this yeah I would say I would say that
would be a if you're gonna go in with
anybody that would probably be something
so you did for him how long does it take
you to shoot an episode I'm fascinated
with this aspect of it up the when do
you get to go home aspect of show
business well there was a lot of writers
meetings you know
a bunch of weeks of that you know just
coming up with the sketches a lot of the
sketch ideas I had already had and then
we shot the sketches also not every one
of them's based on one of your older
bits it's oats some of them are and some
of them are newer ideas
none of the sketches are stand-up done
as a sketch I didn't want to do that
stand up I love stand up and stand up
should be stand up so you do the one
where you wanted to do the cattle prod
and the person who's just standing where
they're supposed to be walking in the
airport that was one of my favorite I'd
like to see somewhere maybe that one
maybe that one I'll do it yeah but I
wanted to stand up to be stand up and
then I wanted some type of transition
into a sketch sometimes it's a natural
lead and sometimes you have to kind of
like horseshoe it you know and but that
was part of the fun too is like
manufacturing these segues and the
sketches so we shot all the sketches and
then we shot all four episodes in two
nights in front of a live audience
where we would throat I do stand up and
then throw down see that perfect
yeah so in theory if we got ten episodes
you could be done by Wednesday for four
and to do a half a on Wednesday like
they have a PTA meeting and then you'd
done yeah it was cool it was cool and
then you know the final night you know
it was happened to be my birthday and
had a big birthday celebration after
that so it was a nice it was a cool
experience that's awesome well my next
next time I do a TV show I don't think
I'm gonna do animation again I tried
that I was being so smart I love my show
I love doing the show but it's just like
it is always you know oh you know every
yeah shut the episode in three days I'm
like Jesus this is a [ __ ] year so
anywho some of the cast members anybody
I know I didn't want a normal cast I
cast per sketch you know so it isn't
like there's a from Isis
against the grain did you did you did
you cast here I want it like if it was a
particular sketch where you had three
characters we would cast for that
particular episode that particular
sketch
I didn't want like a like a MADtv or oh
you don't know and if knowing people
yeah whoever service is the thing you
know okay and so there's some obscure
people but they were all great soon did
not be obscure when this thing debuts
like I said earlier for episodes on
Netflix Christmas Eve so your Florida
guy right yeah what can people expect
from a Florida guy with a sketch show
sorry I just love those questions I also
hate in a social situation when you meet
somebody who just finds out you're
comedian and like every single thing
that said they have to throw in I bet
this is gonna end up in your routine you
should talk about this you know somebody
has a chip and they put some you know
some guacamole on it and it falls on the
table and I bet that's gonna end up in
your ass oh there in front of you in the
buffet line don't put this in your app
yeah you should try to avoid bombing I
mean I might put this in the act because
now we are we're actually they're
actually we're putting it in the act
you did you described the guac falling
off the chip you know I want more of AI
want more celebrities celebrities if I
could say the word telling me about
their political opinions I can't get
enough of it you know because I'm very
unsure on when I think about the world
in which way I'm gonna vote and then all
of a sudden of the six lead on a sitcom
you know informs me about finning or
something and I'm like oh okay that's
that's how that's how I need to think
about that I want to see the flip I want
to see an inauguration ceremony for a
congressman and during his swearing-in
he says who should have one for wardrobe
design in a movie you know criticize
criticize the the Wardrobe winners you
know which of course is absurd but ya
know it's a weird
it's a weird time man you know I've
never felt uh I don't feel old
you know I feel I just feel like it
started with the music I didn't know
what people were listening to I didn't
know what the popular bands was and then
I started to not know who the players
were playing sports mmm and now it's
like yeah I don't know the words you
know I don't know I guess I don't know
no the word says I'm not that bad I just
I just I I don't agree with it when the
Academy Awards come out the it used to
be I had seen all of the movies that are
up for Best Picture then it was like oh
I didn't see that one then it was like
when I saw a couple of them right and
then it got now it's gone to the point
where I've never even heard of any of
them yeah I've never even heard of them
yeah have you heard of him well now
there's so much stuff to watch you heard
they just got rid of another Oscar host
yeah evidently he trips somebody in like
outdoor recess it like in 1983 oh that
was it that was some sort of
kindergarten thing yes yeah I don't
blame him because that was a mistake you
know there was a mistake that he made in
his past and tripping is not really how
many times you apologize for it it's
never cool no I think all I think all
mistakes in life should disqualify
everyone from any future endeavor if
you're human yes yes you know mistakes
should be allowed for in the human
condition only perfect people perfect
people should host award show perfect
people should win Heisman trophies they
should yes um
host award show sorry people like us
perfect people like us for younger kids
now because so much of this [ __ ] is like
on video and just some of their gonna be
funny the amount of the population that
won't be able to run for any sort of
office I just wonder you know there's
always pendulums and everything and
right now the pendulum is over - people
wanna is it pendulum a pendulum you
might be right
I don't know anybody she's Harry
pendulum pendulum oh I'm getting the nod
that I'm right look
look at that but what's pendulum well
it's Angela you know at the Florida
schools pendulum well there did you go
to Ponce de Leon high school I went to
pendulum high school I would defend alum
high Fountain of Youth junior high I
went to Christopher Columbus High School
oh I should talk about you know
politically incorrect in today's world
you know another guy I understand where
we're like where all of that new
evidence came if he did all of that [ __ ]
what did he write it all down he tweeted
it he Twitter they went back tweet dude
you got to do a sketch about that
mamasay go back at a you know it was on
the Santa Maria you know and it's a lot
of time going from Spain or wherever
they left from over to the new world so
he would just sit back in his cabin and
tweet incredible Wi-Fi he went across
that yes
so anyway III went to Columbus High
School I forget the point of I forget
the question and what my answer is I
know but I'm enjoying it all right good
talk anytime you talk about Columbus
tweeting but he should be captain it's
actually a great premise like how
quickly would Hitler get kicked off at
Twitter the second he got on Hitler you
said queer that's a great schedule all
these people and then you gotta have
like you know mother Teresa when she was
young something she did I don't know who
knows uh anyways what's your you still
owe you a college football guy what was
your deal I play I played college fool
that's what it was
a small school Division three so it was
sort of like a school Heidelberg college
and Tiffin Ohio loved my years they're
just you know Midwestern school just
like if you were to film a movie and a
Midwestern campus this is the perfect
place you know just a thousand students
everybody knew each other and future
Supreme Court justices
okay yeah right right it was a perfect
tablet was it underneath what was
happening so I played football there
loved that I actually tried out for a
semi-pro football team what did it
happen to those leaks by the way the AF
a I'm sure you've heard of that no
nobody has the American Football
Association okay and they had a they
were forming this new league so there
was a team gonna form in Orlando called
the Orlando Americans they were gonna
play in the Tangerine Bowl nice a buddy
of mine went up and tried out and they
invited him to camp he's a quarterback
he played at Notre Dame and he said
Regan you should go up there and try out
as a receiver I played receiver in
college and I'm like I am I was out of
shape you know a year and a half after
college because know the the talent up
there is the kind that you could fit in
so I went up and tried out of this big
mass tryout and he invited me to camp
Wow they invited me to camp they brought
nine receivers in the camp but when then
we had to try out from there they were
only gonna keep three receivers they had
like a skeletal squad like two starters
and one backup you know and they cut
down to five I was one of the five I was
one of the five left nice and then they
had I did a post corner pattern and
threw my hip out and I don't think I
would have made it anyway but they cut
me
I'm just pictured you running in your
stand-up crouched like that's why you
threw your hip up what year was it how
old were you sighs should say
well I was like 20 no yeah I was
probably 20 to 22 already too out of
shape yeah that's how come well if it is
right no no I was I meant that as like a
compliment to athletes I had up I think
I had a cousin I played a little
semi-pro football does Olli still exist
is that actually an actual way in C I
feel like it's the CFL or you walk on
and you know or that's it like as far as
getting into the after college to try
and get into the NFL I figure you either
go you stand out at the CFL and even
then that's a long shot or you just try
to get a walk-on right after college
well I had no aspirations of making it
in the NFL zero
you know I but the fact that my buddy
thought I'd go make this one team I
thought well this could be a good
experience for a year or two if I could
get on the team all right
and know that that particularly doesn't
exist anymore so what exactly did you do
to your hip
I did a post corner pattern yeah you
know you 45-degree angle and then cut
back out I had these hip pads that were
too tight and I just remember feeling
like a spine
oh no and was it I have no idea like I
didn't have money to go to a doctor like
that I just couldn't walk kind of hard
to make a team when you can't walk so
you just waited for that feeling to go
away and then you just so it still
hasn't gone away continue down with your
life
it still hurts it still hurts my knee
hurts from football you know when I was
in college I had a knee thing and they
would shoot me up with cortisone for the
games because we had to keep this onh
streak going and they would shoot it
with cortisone it was a it was amazing
because the pain was so intense when
they didn't shoot me up like I could
barely walk and then they would shoot me
up before the games and I I'm gonna
field running around like a deer you
know like I felt like Bambi
like but while I'm running I'm
practically hearing crunch crunch crunch
crunch crunch crunch
wisten my knee up you know
and I finally quit I quit college
because of the knee I was worried that I
was gonna do permanent damage to it did
you I mean it still hurts it a little
bit here and there but yeah yeah you one
of those weather guys knee starts acting
up you're like there's gonna be a
twister that's my hip it's gonna be a
cold front
I can tell asteroids when an asteroid is
coming oh really
that's interesting yeah is that your hip
or your knee but my hip is like if
there's an incoming asteroid and my knee
lets me know if there's an earthquake
coming those at unwired bazaar you know
what I think here at all things comedy
we could cut a side deal with The
Weather Channel you know let's just head
over to Regan anything hurting the Regan
Report oh I feel a magnitude-6 coming on
you know I really resent two channels
that I used to actually enjoy was The
Weather Channel I actually used to like
watching it and for some stupid reason
and the Discovery Channel and both of
them you know I don't know I don't know
what they did I don't like how they you
know the Discovery Channel further like
make sharks look out like they're just
inherently mean things you know with all
this [ __ ] going on you know we sit there
at me whenever you watch you know
something on sharks they're always
telling you know people is a
misconception about it but then the
whole way they they sell Shark Week is
that jaws vibe right you know they put a
ski mask on him and stuff they always
said they've been typecast and I would
think with all this progressive talk out
there that someone would speak up for
them and then the Weather Channel they
went the way the food network well they
used to just tell you what the weather
was and they'd have some weirdo and now
it's like all personality driven and
they got to make it sound like Jesus is
gonna show up every time it [ __ ]
rains
those are my issues those are the things
that keep me up at night I feel that
about CNN Headline News not regular CNN
CNN Headline News used to be thirty
minutes of just news with the most
middle-of-the-road news anchor right and
I'm like this is the way it's supposed
to be just a guy just telling you nice
and straight what's going on and now
it's personnel
yeah just like you're talking about
these other gyms angry people hot chicks
this person that person yeah I saw one
the other night the local LA news here
and they teased this for half an hour
a guy got cut off on a motorcycle went
over his handlebars on the highway got a
couple of bumps and bruises but was fine
right but he filmed it he had a little
camera on top of his head
so they just kept filming the footage on
the five South may in happens it's this
guy's splitting lanes
I mean it's legal out here but that's
what he's doing the guy just went you
know the guy went to change lanes didn't
see him he hit went up and over they're
like yeah after he teased it the whole
[ __ ] like this this is an actual news
right right that if you ride a
motorcycle in LA you could probably
gonna go down at some point and he
didn't even get [ __ ] hurt if he died
I'd be like well alright but it wasn't
it was like I was like the first draft
of a script it's like we got to raise
the stakes can he can he go over the
handlebars into the oncoming traffic can
we get some can we get some of that but
the whole thing and he just led for 20
minutes they teased it and then I
finally see the footage that I already
been watching they didn't have any more
footage and then they interviewed him
and he like how do you feel yeah you
know I'm alright you know I guess it was
news cuz the guy who hit him walked up
to him said are you okay and he said yes
and then he got in the car and peeled
away
so they had his face looking at him you
know so I guess that I guess that was
the news as well like whether it was a
hit-and-run like he didn't care enough
the guy who hit him well he took off
yeah I think he did plenty he I doubt he
got out he said you are the mistake he
made is he peeled away that indicates
guilt what he should have done was just
signaled and got back on the highway and
just that guy I thought he was fine I
got out I asked him I knew he had the
GoPro on I knew I was on camera so I
didn't do anything wrong
he had a helmet on ffense attorney I
didn't have a helmet I was fine I
figured he'd be fine to look look at the
side of my car I was out here in LA one
time watching the local news they said
we have breaking news right and they had
helicopter footage of a home who's the
garage was on fire and I'm the only
person that would possibly give
damn about this garage being on fire is
the guy who lives in that house nobody
else would care about that garage being
on fire yet it was breaking news well it
used to be when I lived out here in the
90s I remember I was just like this news
out here is a [ __ ] joke and then
somewhere along the line national news
caught up to what they were doing out
here in LA cuz when I kind of stopped I
don't know if this is probably a bad
thing but I kind of stopped watching the
[ __ ] like at least seven years ago like
right now I'm trying to remember the
name of the vice president the first one
that I thought was Joe Biden but that
was the last one Mike Pence migrants
yeah yeah okay see that I mean that's
literally the backup quarterback to the
United States I don't know his [ __ ]
name I can understand not knowing the
was the Secretary of Defense the
treasurer the I know those the
coordinator of because they keep
changing in the current administration
so it is hard to keep up but usually
when they when they ride for years I can
remember them all oh is that what is
that I don't I don't pretend you know
all right so what else can we talk about
here anything anything else you want to
promote you get some stand-up dates
Connor I'm in a I'm in a I get to wear
the actor's hat and a show called
Loudermilk the ferret of milk Farrelly
Brothers Peter Farrelly Dumb and Dumber
and all that they've done some things
yeah well a huge they're like no funnies
[ __ ] people ever
well Peter Farrelly and a guy named
Bobby Mort created a show called
Loudermilk it's about substance abuse
dark comedy it's on DIRECTV's audience
Network we just got picked up for our
third season I play a guy recovering
from substance abuse and I love it I
never did a never had an opportunity to
do a lot of acting and uh sounds great I
I it's just so much fun what is your
character addicted to alcohol quaaludes
the whole thing had a big family and had
a falling-out with his family and the
whole thing and but it's funny but
serious and funny mostly funny and Ron
Livingston plays the the main dude and
it's like going wrong yeah and it's like
group discussion thing you know like an
a a meeting but it's about people's I
have DirecTV how can I see this it's on
the audience network every Tuesday night
audience network so is that somewhere in
my thing if you have DirecTV you should
have the audience network it's just a
channel on there what channel
I think to 39 to 39 what 500 500 Jesus
Christ you won't even close this [ __ ]
thing you don't know what channel right
now it's on to 30 now where I live it's
it on 500 as well oh I don't know but on
the bus it's 500 all right so if you're
in a house it's 239 if because the
channels are the same but DirecTV that's
what I like because I am having DirecTV
you go on the road and I like going to
the hotel already
I know ESPN is gonna be 206 207 208 you
know the redhead channel is a 798 I get
the ginger report see if it's okay to go
outside Jesus Christ oh you playing
everything close to the vest what else
you got going on he had talked to you if
like [ __ ] half hour before I find out
you're in a third season of a show yeah
that's all right
a lot of people don't know about it you
know it's an obscure it's hard a lot of
people haven't seen it yet but it's
getting a lot of good buzz and starting
to get some traction don't you feel like
you almost have to do three seasons of a
show now just for the general population
to know that it exists it's amazing to
me I mean when I started in this
business if I would have thought that I
would be on a TV show that my friends
didn't even know about and I'm not
exaggerating I have friends who go oh
really you're on a show and it's like my
parents have never seen the show that
I'm on just for the simple fact they
can't figure out Netflix like they came
from an agent just walked up you just
pulled the knob turned on the TV for
five or seven what do you want to watch
so then I can sit that guy do what and
then they got and then they gotta type
in and search like they're just gonna be
I'm not I'm not you know I'm not [ __ ]
doing that they they are they are old
school so yeah I actually talked to
somebody if told this story before I
talked one night I was talking to
another comedian and I was telling her
how much she liked how much I liked her
show she was taking on it's great we
talked for 10 minutes before she
realized the show I was talking about
had already been canceled and she
thought I was talking about a different
TV show that she was on that I had never
heard of that's Crittenden I told her
that I had a TV show and she had never
heard of that dance and I was like you
understand how [ __ ] I could see if we
both worked in a lumberyard or one of us
did but we're both in this business
you're like you're like shootin you know
you don't even know what you're aiming
at and we're both on beyond the first
season so there is some sort of success
to both that shows that were on and we
still have no we still haven't heard
about him Wow anyways where you can I
saw I had an embarrassing moment with
the Colin Quinn
it showed tough tough crowd mm-hm and
you know I saw him at a charity event or
something like that and said hey man so
what you know I'm loving you on tough
crowd
mhm and he said it's been off the air
for like four years you know okay you
just feel so stupid you know that's that
was the conversation first conversation
I have a Colin Quinn I see there was a
movie out that he was getting credit for
writing oh my god what the [ __ ] was it
called it was it was the one with Damon
Wayans in it the Celtic Celtic pride
okay I met him at my first comics come
home and and we're literally out in
front of the crowd I can't believe I
worked with Colin Quinn Dennis Leary and
all of these guys the crowds doing a
standing ovation [ __ ] Cam Neely
standing there I'm like three years in
the business right I can't believe I'm a
part of this and I see Colin and I'm
like oh my god that's Colin Quinn for
more remote-control SNL and oh boy what
do I say to this guy so I and I was just
oh because I audition for the movie so I
lied and said I saw it cuz I didn't see
it I said hey man I really enjoyed
Celtic pride and he goes I didn't write
that piece of [ __ ] they took that away
from us oh my god I said the exact wrong
thing that's what I get for trying to
kiss ass and I made a mental note to
never tell somebody that I saw a movie
that I didn't see again and I've broken
that you have to in this business you
have to do it
speaking of golf golfing did you say you
were golfing with right with Colin that
we hit we met on you met him on a golf
general
at a charity show it was where I saw
Jesus so [ __ ] burnt out I came to
listen to my goddamn guests well you you
golf I gotta go I gotta go on this thing
when is this thing gonna be here Brian
game comes out to me go dude you got to
go on this this three-day it's like it's
like a spa right yeah give your sober up
right chill out right nothing lighter a
lot of fruits and vegetables and we golf
probiotics we do hot yoga we go back we
have a we do hot yoga and then hip
aligned again and a lot of meditating
yeah a lot of meditating and it's just
so it's so good for all all the fellas
yeah to get together grateful do that
yeah when is the next one
uh probably May but yeah love to have
you involved man I always feel like
whenever I run into you the few times
that I go on the wagon I then that's
when I run into you I had my boobs with
you it was in New York and that was that
time it was it was it wasn't just the
guys it was men and women's right picked
like this fancy [ __ ] place and that
waiter came over and you you ordered
like a Budweiser or something like like
I sorry Missy we did not have it we have
is either the divan you just staring at
I'm waiting for him to finish you're
like is that a beer oui Monsieur and
you're like okay I'll have one of those
[Laughter]
and then I saw you more recently at that
bar in New York and you weren't you
weren't having cocktails at the time and
then I felt guilty I'm like I'm like six
in here no I mean once in a while I just
like I you know I shut it down for a
little while I'm gonna hopefully shoot
another special coming up soon and I
just don't want to go through the whole
[ __ ] I got a drop you know 20 pounds of
pizza and beer I don't feel like doing
that this time around so am I also doing
it during the holiday so my game plan is
I'll be three weeks in on Saturday I'm
taking one night off which is dangerous
for me because I'm a big binge drinker
yeah I mean I'm goal-oriented you know I
see a bottom on
finish it right now one of these these
half-assed people that leave sink in the
dish dishes in the sink sorry can you
speak no so I'm gonna make it dinner for
my wife and then I'm gonna we're gonna
drink a split a bottle of wine there you
and then the game plan is to immediately
go back on the wagon however one of my
buddies from New York is also in town
and he said hey let's hang out Monday
something oh maybe Monday and Monday
and this is what happens then it become
Sunday Monday Tuesday hmm all right the
next thing you know yeah I love I think
we chatted about this in the past ie I I
get my work done you know I work hard on
what I do and I I put my nose to the
grindstone you know I mean but you're
giving me the classic I work hard play
hard you guys can see that the when I
there's my hand movement Trump's gotta
get this one down it's like it's like
the thumb and index finger everything
else is lined up and then the pinkies up
I get a little teacup but when I I'm
gonna go out you know like and I'm safe
about it car service the whole thing
guys together you know getting ballistic
I like those moments or those evenings
um it's very good I love those months
yeah you know when you get a lit up half
the year I hate the winter I don't want
to remember it that's right I want to be
warm
that's what hibernation is all about
yeah so it's not probably not a good
message for people out there but problem
with it it's like Jesus Christ my vice
yeah that's my vice yeah that is mine
too so I I you know I shut it down for a
couple of months and then I slowly start
back up again and then when I just I
just feel like it's getting out of
control of like I'm just you know I'm
just living too much of a you know I
don't know just too much of a slothful
dose because what happens is everything
goes off the rails it's not just okay
I'm having too many cocktails it's like
I'm also eating a steak and cheese you
want a fries side salad I'll take the
fries well-done I start doing that [ __ ]
so you know
it's a neurologist I sort of dial it
back in and I dial it back and I get
eight hours sleep and I I'm just sort of
I like it in the morning but the rest of
the day I'm sad so you like waking up
like having not Yanks the night before
and go ahead it's not like sad you know
eight hours sleep nobody to apologize to
but then you know once after breakfast
man it's just really like the gloom all
right next week and you're in yeah I'm
definitely in for that is it well you're
in Vegas right is it gonna be out there
I don't know if I could do I don't think
I think I know if this next one's in
Florida we do it in a different place
every every Jesus Christ hey the pickety
here it's all the way on the other side
of the [ __ ] country I'm gonna I'm
will spring for a private jet for you
can you know can you just book me at a
Magellan's [ __ ] comedy club every
comedy club down there always seems to
be like you know the captain hook the
barge whatever the [ __ ] the tugboat
Tommy's down in Boca ratone
that guy from the Florida Keys he books
uh he books almost to Cuba comedy club
whatever all right sorry I'm sitting
here reading trying to make dumb jokes
alright so stand-up in a way for
episodes Netflix Christmas Eve are you
gonna be celebrating the holidays or
anything like that
New Year's Eve I'm performing well
finally I get you to [ __ ] plug a date
what how does it take me 20 minute he he
just told me because I didn't plug him
on any other thing he said you know if
there's no opportunity this is Dave my
tour guy smart guy yeah he said you know
part of this is plugging things he
didn't say it that way he goes if you
cannot plug your New Year's Eve date so
here I am gonna fit here I am smoothly
plugging my New Year's Eve date Chicago
the Chicago Theatre ah New Year's Eve
that's tremendous but that I'm not
bringing in the new year I'm not on
stage doing the countdown I always what
time's your show eight o'clock it'll be
over you know like 9:30 9:45 but I want
people in Chicago knowing that like you
come to the show
and then you go to a party and have fun
I'm not gonna you know it's such a
letdown I've done those and then you got
to come out and it's like a DJ still
spinning or they want you to keep doing
your [ __ ] joke now I can't I can't I
can't be a an emcee to the countdown and
they've already shut off the bar so
everybody's just standing there sort of
starting to sober up here yeah like I
was in rules I worked this many years at
this job so I can count from ten to zero
backwards you know I've done that so
many [ __ ] element God all those years
of doing that I don't even work New
Year's anymore
I work a couple extra in November and
December and then I just I take that
night off so I'm gonna take my wife out
is what I'm gonna do there you go she
doesn't know that yet you just surprised
yeah so that's what I'm gonna do all
right so that's it everybody Brian Regan
everybody by the way do you is such a
huge influence on me you're one of the
greatest comics I've ever seen and just
decade after decade just still in you
know the upper echelon everybody always
brings you up when they go the best guys
ever the best [ __ ] albums and all of
that stuff so if you're in the Chicago
area
New Year's Eve it's an 8 o'clock show
he's not doing the countdown so get some
friends to hang you know go to the show
and then afterwards pick a bar and last
time stand up and away for episodes
Netflix Christmas Eve hey let before you
wrap up I have to say I think you're a
genius I think you're wonderful at what
you do when you throw me a compliment
that way it means the world to me I love
watching your craft and how much you put
into it you have a wonderful comedic
mind so that compliment coming from you
means the world to me thank you and you
said that perfectly just the way I wrote
it out I love you brother
all right man Happy New Year and Merry
Christmas and we will golf and make a
right all right let's do a little bit of
advertising here tipsy elves everyone
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater
this time of year do you want the
bragging rights for the most talked
about sweater at the holiday parties
then wait till you see tipsy elves
hilarious reimagined in a reverent
designed you better get these soon man
it's almost Christmas here stylish
Christmas suits for the classiest of
holiday gentlemen interactive sweaters
OG got the huh in this climate I don't
know about that beer pong cornhole
drinking game darts so Uncle Bob can
relive his college glory days at the
family dinner how is that interactive do
I not know the definition that must be
the third definition in the dictionary
interactive to participate with another
person definition number two get down to
three it's like ugly Christmas sweater
um anyways and even hilarious themed
tees and awesome cozy onesies for for
women holiday dresses so you can get
down with your bad elf oh Jesus that's
such a mom SUV joke I love it i catching
leggings if you're not happy in your
marriage so you can strike a festive
yoga pose Thursday E or a lounge around
with the cup of spiked eggnog and T's
that sleigh and cute comfy onesies they
even sell bright and crazy ski suits but
when you're shredding some NAR this
holiday season going west coast on that
one you won't find some Holly you won't
find more hilariously awesome designs
anywhere else so be sure to order from
tipsy elves in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party and right now my
listeners get play percent off at tipsy
elves calm when you use my code BB Bravo
Bravo at checkout that's 20% off
anything you order on the site go to
tipsy elves comm and enter my code BB at
checkout to get you 20% off site-wide
discount Dollar Shave Club Doh Dollar
Shave club's everything you need to look
feel and smell your best and you never
have to go to the store that's because
they deliver everything you need right
to your [ __ ] dua and they keep you
fully stocked and what you use so you
don't run out here's how it works
here's how it works Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to get ready and
they just said this no matter what
you're getting ready for they have you
covered head to toe your hair your skin
your face you know you just said here I
was work he going back in a more
can copy they have a new program where
you keep you eyes you automatically
stocked up with the products you use you
determine what you want and when you
want it out of [ __ ] do you do it from
once a month to once every six months oh
yeah I guess you do it on the website
Jesus that was like somebody telling a
bad [ __ ] story like we get to the
point plus what they're handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
save
and right now done I'm not good at math
but that doesn't make sense right now
Dollar Shave Club has a bunch of status
sets you can try for just five bucks
like their oral care kit after that the
restock box ships regular size products
at regular price get your starter set
for just five dollars right now at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bur for just five
dollars alright last one everybody hims
40% of men by age 40 struggle from not
being able to get and maintain an
erection because they're thinking too
much even if the world even if the
world's greatest actor even the greatest
world's greatest actor can't fake one
why do you guys turn to weird solutions
or do nothing I don't know cuz you get
shamed for it
you know we're gonna go on Oprah and
talk about that my peepee won't work
when they can turn to instead to
medicine and science for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual sexual wellness for men answer a
few quick questions and chat with the
doctor for confidential review how does
you do you mean I know blood goes into
your dick that's got to be like a garage
door in there you know like a valve
you know it's like a reverse varicose
vein it's like this is the one you want
products are shipped directly to your
door right answer a few quick questions
and chat with a doctor for confidential
review products products are shipped
directly to your door severe Edie isn't
just an issue for rich old guys and
bathtubs it affects men in their 30s and
40s ah god bless you you got to get
these guys up and running
this is like gas monkey for you dick
you know like a garage fine being your
best means performing your best it's a
wreck tile without the dysfunction hard
made easy say hello to say a lot to a
little friend try hymns for a month for
just five bucks will get you started for
just for just five bucks while supplies
last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to the doctor
or a pharmacy go to forums calm / burr
Edie for that's for hims calm fo are
hims calm / / Edie Capaldi Edie alright
no space between Bernie D for hims calm
/ / Edie all right now listen to a
little bit of music and we got another
half hour greatest hits from from some
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast from earlier this
year
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the holiday season dooby-dooby-doo
who sings that song what's up it's bill
Bert's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 13 2010 how the hell are
you
I've had that [ __ ] song in my head I
heard it on the radio in like the
grocery store you know I was grown going
in there to go buy a ham some glazed you
know gelatinous [ __ ] right and I was in
there and there was this song on the on
the speaker's there of the ceiling so
the grocery store that I just mentioned
I was at if you forgot already you know
and I'm driving around I got this big
[ __ ] ham sitting in my grocery cart
and elk through the speakers it's just
this guy it sounded like it was from
maybe the 50s you know it's the holiday
season dooby-dooby-doo
I can't remember if he went doobie
doobie Doo or that's just how I remember
hearing it I'm trying to give you more
lyrics she's like I gotta know the name
of this song cuz I want to download it I
wanna drive around La and 80 degree
weather on Christmas you know with a
stupid look on my face listening to that
song how the rest of it goes it's the
holiday season something like that I
can't remember you know that is you know
one that you know the the what is it
when they do that thing where you know
that that elevator music from the 1950s
where they actually took like sort of
like blues progression and I don't know
what they did to it so it's almost like
still has like the bad but that but
they're but they're dead maybe that's
more swing and you [ __ ] stick it in
you cut something like that but
obviously it's a lot more uh has a lot
more family values to it whatever it's
the holiday season so please for the
love of God so I'll stop singing this
[ __ ] song somebody somebody let me
know what the name of that song is okay
and before I forget which I don't know
how I would alright
you know we do underrated overrated
every week you guys remember that for
the last three [ __ ] years of me doing
it just about every Monday I got one for
you underrated the Black Crowes underage
despite the fact that they're selling
out these huge venues they're still
underrated I went to go see him Saturday
night I say as they say in Boston it's
amazing they actually take that word
that has so many consonants and they
remove all of them like a cancer when
you're gonna come on come over say
Saturday night at the Palladium the same
place where Richard Pryor taped live on
the Sunset Strip I went down and I saw
the Black Crowes play Truth and salvage
company opening up and the Black Crowes
played three hours people three hours
hour-and-a-half acoustic set and then
they take a break like [ __ ] barely 12
minutes and they come back out again
basically after kicking the [ __ ] out of
the crowd for an hour and a half they
take a 12 minute break right just enough
to go back you know have a cigarette and
a little shot of Gatorade and they go
right back out again and kick the [ __ ]
out of the crowd for another hour and a
half it's easily the
best show I've seen in like 10 12 years
and I don't I just go see him they're up
in San Francisco if you're in the area
they're playing the film or all this all
this week and they were unbelievable and
the greatest thing that I liked about it
was everything that you were hearing was
being produced by human beings that the
humans that were on the stage as opposed
to all this other [ __ ] that you go to
see now I'm not saying these people
aren't talented but you know I've been
flipping through the channels like an
old man you know four fingers the inside
the [ __ ] waistband in my pajamas you
know if the guy you know the [ __ ] was
that married with children just sitting
there you know you got the remote the
other hand clicking through and you see
like like you know these little
pop-tarts even a guy like Usher who's
tremendously talented the singing and
the dancing and all that [ __ ]
you're hearing all of these instruments
that are not on the [ __ ] stage and
then you're also hearing like I can't
say with him I can't remember who
exactly it was but like you hear at
least it's like the person is singing
with themselves they have the track
going and it's like so I don't know
musically socially acceptable now like
back in the day if you got busted doing
that that was like the end of your
[ __ ] career everybody's just saying
he's a [ __ ] sellout me and and that
was it he didn't sell [ __ ]
so the [ __ ] am I trying to say it was
awesome it was unbelievable show and
recently I finally started downloading
us actually some little feet tube and
like 20 years ago the guys I worked with
in this warehouse with telling me I
should get into him when I finally got
around to doing it and downloaded their
greatest hits and that live album Christ
what's it called waiting for Columbus I
believe and they have a song on there
called willin and I'd listen to it and
someone was saying oh yeah the guy wrote
it and that's why he got kicked out of
[ __ ] Frank Zappa's band and then he
made [ __ ] and he got with little
flock story short the Black Crowes ended
up
they closed out their set singing that
song it was it was that was just a [ __ ]
it was even the way they ended their set
they didn't do the big [ __ ] you know
you know where they just sitting there
strumming that one note in the guitars
the [ __ ] drummer sitting there
smashing all the cymbals
thanks a lot can afford you been great
good I didn't even do that they played
this really cool [ __ ] song and it
ended on this nice just I was still with
the [ __ ]
there was the [ __ ] so if you get a
chance to see him please go see him and
the drummer of that band Steve Gorman
has a podcast and a few baseball fans
out there just or sports fans in general
it's a sports podcast and this week
Tuesday I believe he's gonna upload it
he interviewed Youkilis from the Red Sox
so please check that out and if you're
not into sports please go see them at
the Fillmore I'm sure they're already
sold out but it was it was [ __ ]
awesome so there you go there's my plug
I am in a generous mood this week you
know why cuz it's the holiday season
dooby dooby doo and you stick it up you
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry I just I got a jar
this song loose in my head I'm gonna
figure out what it is so anyways well
well well a lot has happened since the
last time I did my podcast hasn't it
boys and girls a lot of things have
happened
does anybody know what I'm talking about
just you know is it an amazing thing
about life that in six short days seven
days if you're into math how many
[ __ ] things can happen in just a
little seven day period if you go back
eight days and you think of what you
thought about certain aspects of the
world and how different your opinion is
a mere eight days later what would be a
good example of that ass [ __ ] I don't
know let's see let's let's just take
your average [ __ ] Joe from eight days
ago like I don't know let's say like a
Jets fan a Jets fan eight [ __ ] days
ago huh
what are my god I was just looking at my
[ __ ] mic recorder I thought that
whole thing I thought I thought I didn't
record it I thought I thought I thought
he said you wanted one I thought the
thing it's shut off let's continue here
god damn it I just [ __ ] up my momentum
a Jets fan eight days ago what the [ __ ]
were they thinking huh I'm walking
around now people eight days ago those
[ __ ] thought that they were
gonna win the Superbowl
you know probably thought that they were
gonna go into Foxborough grab [ __ ]
Tom Brady with his by his updated mullet
slap him around a little bit put a
couple of more dimples into his chin
that's what they thought was gonna
happen
eight [ __ ] days later eight days
later right now every jet fan in the
country eject them has their green
[ __ ] head between their knees looking
at their [ __ ] green balls shriveling
up pulling up into their [ __ ] abdomen
alright
there's a deal I'm not gonna talk [ __ ] I
talked a little bit of [ __ ] I had to
because of all the [ __ ] emails I've
been getting and not just from jet fans
that [ __ ] dick from Philly you know
who you are when you've sent me that
email gonna bill give it up give it up
already you sound like a [ __ ] the Jets
are [ __ ] the will they're the best
team in the AFC and all that [ __ ] all
right I'm gonna say this say it real
quick cuz I don't feel like I need to
say anything but I'm a [ __ ] so I'm gonna
continue talking about this okay what if
what what the [ __ ] did I tell you what
did I say
I [ __ ] said I'm not even saying that
they can't still pull it together and
maybe win the Super Bowl but to refresh
your memory at the beginning of the
season when I was watching those [ __ ]
morons on that HBO Hard Knocks thing
running their mouths that's what as why
are they talking all this [ __ ] they're
talking as if they already won one two
three [ __ ] championships and you
remember what I said I said the Patriots
the [ __ ] Ravens the Steelers the
Chargers or even the Dolphins could beat
this [ __ ] team on any given Sunday
and lo and behold
within six days two [ __ ] losses you
know so that's it I had to give you one
I told yourself all right and here's one
for you
Jets fans if you think I'm thinking that
the Patriots are [ __ ] gonna win the
Superbowl and that the defense I saw the
last two [ __ ] weeks is their defense
now you're sadly mistaken this is why
you [ __ ] get disappointed every year
is because you see you see half a ray of
sunlight and you think dad that's what
it is I still don't like our defense all
right - [ __ ] great weeks in a row
does not make up for the fact that you
[ __ ] the bed and let up 24 to 30 points
for the first [ __ ] of 11 weeks or
whatever the hell nine weeks whatever I
don't know no 11 weeks we would nine and
two that's right
the first 11 weeks so I don't know who
do you like some reason I'm thinking the
Ravens sitting there all quietly nestled
in Baltimore right no one's paying
attention to him Joe Flacco I don't know
I know we beat him this year but I don't
know if trying to beat those guys twice
in one year so I'm not I'm not [ __ ]
saying anything so there you go that is
it and having said that how [ __ ]
hilarious I really felt that is this
something here I
felt really bad for the strength and
conditioning coach who stuck his knee
out
and knocked that dolphin guide down all
right
I felt really [ __ ] bad for that guy
because that was such a classic
spur the moment completely out of
character move it was just the right set
of circumstances had they beat the
Patriots the week before he wouldn't
have done that [ __ ]
had they bounced back and they were
beating the Dolphins he wouldn't have
done that [ __ ] he's never done anything
like that was just the classic that spur
the moment like it was just [ __ ] we got
killed by the Patriots [ __ ] we're losing
this game he's a competitive psycho cuz
that's how you get to that level right
it was just all line I'm telling you
that guy like I don't think he's a bad
guy
I really don't it was a it was a piece
of [ __ ] thing to do but you know there's
so many [ __ ] people in jail because
of a moment like that they had never
committed a crime their entire [ __ ]
life and just two major shifts happened
in their [ __ ] life and then an
opportunity presented itself do you
think about how many times you go down
this you walk down the street you see
somebody bent over tying this shoe and
your brain just goes why just go [ __ ]
boot him in the ass right but you don't
because the other side of you is going
wait a minute can't boot this guy in the
ass what if he knows that [ __ ] UFC
[ __ ] comes over and [ __ ] you know
blows out my eye and I look like [ __ ]
Josh Koscheck over the [ __ ]
cross-check of yusei's [ __ ] name
right or what if what if I get arrested
for assault what if I get sued like that
voice just beats down that other voice
cone god damn look at those titties once
you go and just grab them titties
they're right there grab them
but you don't because you have a job she
got a family cuz you're working towards
something and it's it's going relatively
well you're on course but then what
happens you know girlfriend dumps you
you know you lose your [ __ ] job it
starts to unravel and when it starts to
unravel that voice in your head you know
that guy right in the balls become so
[ __ ] loud that that other voice of
reason it's now it's way in the back of
your head you can't even hear it anymore
and that's what the [ __ ] happened to
that guy it was just it was dude I'm
telling you last night last night that
dude was sitting there why is this
[ __ ] thing saying I'm peaking now was
it too loud I'm trying to overcompensate
for the fact that people were saying
that my podcasts were too quiet trying
to overcompensate there we go why is
that light sitting there going peak
hello Tess want to test well [ __ ] you
okay so evidently that the reason why it
said peak was because I had reached the
memory limit for my LS 10 all right I
deleted some [ __ ] I'm back so anyways
the [ __ ] was I taught I was talking
about that guy I guarantee you he's not
a bad guy last night he was sitting
there talking to his wife he couldn't
even sleep his wife or his girlfriend
you know she's sitting down in the
corner you know holding her knees
sitting in the corner going why did you
do that and he's like I don't know I
don't know why I did it like Gus Grissom
and the right stuff it was there was a
glitch the hatch gets blue I don't know
why I did it I was standing there we
were losing the [ __ ] game with a guy
came by I just
I only stuck it out a little bit man I
just stuck it out a little bit he sees
he's just [ __ ] muttering to himself
why did I do that why the [ __ ] why did I
do that that was so [ __ ] Stu this
guy's in prison right now
why did that why did I listen to that
voice why I paid my taxes I was a Cub
Scout right I [ __ ] made sandwiches
for my kids sent him off to school
and then just that one day my [ __ ]
neighbor
excuse me Carl can I talk to you for a
second um I know you've discussed this
before is there any way you could just
not have your dog relieve himself on my
lawn and that just happens to be a
[ __ ] shovel and you're just looking
at his mouth you know and you just pedal
with the shovel bang you [ __ ] do it
then you're like [ __ ] get up please get
up please get up
did anybody see that bury the shovel man
and then you just go down that road and
you've never committed a [ __ ] crime
and then you end up in jail it was just
because of that one the circumstances
were there I don't think that that guy's
a bad guy I don't it was just
you know the problem is they're being
led by a crazy man
Rex Ryan is out of his [ __ ] mind
another thing that I've said since last
[ __ ] year okay that guy I don't know
if he's bipolar or if he's manic
depressive alright but I am a psycho and
I can spot another psycho from [ __ ]
across the room that guy is out of his
mind and what the you know you gotta buy
into your coach's philosophy alright so
they bought into his [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] John Wayne horseshit when he was
having they didn't realize he was having
a manic episode you know all the coaches
signing that bus as he's walking up and
the depths of his insecurities saying
that you know you don't even deserve to
be here he had to so overcompensate for
it he just by the time he grabbed that
sharpie his manic episode was so through
the [ __ ] roof he just starts writing
on the wall
we're gonna win the Super Bowl he did
that and he brought all his players up
to this manic [ __ ] level and when you
go that high you crashed that [ __ ]
low and that's what happened in two
weeks
this [ __ ] the strength and
conditioning coach no pain no gain
you gotta want it that guy whose dad was
probably like Emilio Estevez Estevez oh
and [ __ ] you say his name his dad and in
The Breakfast Club weird weird weird I
hate you you son of a [ __ ]
that was his dad so he's got that
information up there
he's got Rex Ryan's manic little is
doable right in his [ __ ] head and it
comes his dread Mladic locked jackass
running right by him
sticky nail stick your [ __ ] knee out
and he just went with it he saw him he's
trying to fight it his other nice going
no no no stay back here with me and the
other knees like [ __ ] dad I'm going in
I'm [ __ ] going and he stuck it out
and that [ __ ] dude Jesus do you ever
think that you could take down a
professional athlete that easily he
looked like he fell out of a car he got
kneed in the side of the leg on the
40-yard line he didn't stop rolling to
like the [ __ ] 12 yard line ah can you
imagine that the second he did that [ __ ]
that poor bastard I I bet it felt like a
cold like he was standing under a
[ __ ] ice water waterfall that even
makes sense and then that would be like
hail I could have just said hail
whatever it's [ __ ] cold and he's
standing at it and I bet he could even
feel this [ __ ] from his his goddamn
heart down he probably couldn't feel
anything just going like oh my god what
did I just do oh my god
please get up please please get up [ __ ]
did anybody see that did Rex see that
why did I do that oh my god oh my god
what if I get fired but if I get fired
he [ __ ] went through all of that [ __ ]
that poor bastard you know but I gotta
admit as a Patriots fan I don't ever
have to listen to the [ __ ] Jets fans
talk about cheating anymore do I
is the post gonna have that caught
cheating with a little asterisk next to
it for the rest of the [ __ ] season oh
you green [ __ ] so there you go whatever
so that's that's this week in football
that is this week in football how about
those [ __ ] Minnesota Vikings with
their inflatable roof you know can you
imagine if that happened during a game
even with helmets on I think somebody
could die it's a weird thing because
it's snow you think like it's just gonna
be like you know getting a snowstorm
over with in like a half a second but
that was probably a good couple hundred
pounds of snow and I don't know about
you guys I don't want a couple hundred
pounds of anything landing on me from
the top of a [ __ ] dome Stadium
Jesus Christ that was one of the saddest
moments I've ever seen for a
professional franchise you know
getting ready to play the New York
Giants New York Football Giants how you
guys want it you want it they're [ __ ]
big blue [ __ ] bring it at 20 minutes
you got a callback
yeah listen her about that football game
uh anyway we could do it on Monday
Monday would probably work a little bit
better cuz yeah stadium collapsed and we
have to we have to get a bicycle pump
and we have to repair it little duct
tape yeah but uh I figured Detroit's in
between your city and our cities
you know sort of equidistant and it's
just a suggestion
oh yeah just call me back okay all right
buh-bye [ __ ] so anyways let's get into
the podcast here this week so that's it
I'm done [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
and I got to tell you something I'm
gonna Pat myself on the back I could
have been a lot meter I could have been
a lot meter and you know what I gotta be
honest with you if I believed in our
defense a little more I think I would
have been I think I would have been how
you doing down there in San Diego my is
your team slapped you around enough this
year Jesus Christ whatever you do do not
bet on the [ __ ] charges you don't
know who the [ __ ] gonna show up it's
kill or be killed
rape or be raped that's what the [ __ ]
going on down in San Diego they're
either gonna win 41 nothing or lose 56
to 8
they got a safety that's how they got
the 8 all right now two field goals in a
safety right is that other works maybe
they wait for a two-point conversion I'm
just trying to cover all the bases for
the [ __ ] mathletes out there all
right let's move let's move on here oh
here's something that somebody sent me
they mentioned that they'd seen Paul
McCartney a Beatle on why don't I just
read the email what let's who's kidding
who let's be honest why don't I just
attempt to read this email okay hey Bill
I just finished watching last night's
Saturday Night Live with Paul McCartney
and I think it's time for
Paul to hang it up for good I feel like
a bit of an [ __ ] for thinking it
because we're all supposed to be in awe
of him because he's a Beatle they let
him do four songs last night because
everyone is in awe of him and that's the
problem no one wants to tell the 68 year
old man with the dyed brown hair and
saggy man boobs that he doesn't have the
voice for a live performance anymore I
fear getting old and being irrelevant to
but I hope that when it's my time to
retire I can accept that I'm not what I
once was and move on to something else
that better suits that stage of my life
Paul should look to someone like Bono
not that I'm a big Bono fan but I think
he's done it right by imitating Bob
Geldof's example of rock and roll
philanthropy how about a pat him in the
back for getting through that sentence
without [ __ ] it up you two won't draw
stadium-sized crowds forever so bono set
set himself up as a jet-setting friend
of the world's poor Ian if he never
gave another concert or some another
note he'd still have a meaningful he'll
still have meaningful work beyond his
music it's like you were saying in
previous podcasts it's good to have a
side business in case show business
doesn't work out best regards um yeah I
kind of see what you're saying a little
bit but I know a lot of people saw Paul
McCartney last year on tour and said he
was [ __ ] unbelievable and then I also
think that the Beatles right now are a
victim of a backlash because of
something that they didn't create I
think Apple not Apple is what have
iTunes that's right
iTunes I got real confused there because
they had Apple Records and then
Macintosh has a [ __ ] Apple and that's
all it takes to really just send me
flying down the [ __ ] sideline like
that dreadlocked son of a [ __ ] who got
tripped anyways I think iTunes has been
trying to get the Beatles catalog
obviously it's probably the first band
you would want to start with as far as
if you wanted to make money they finally
got them and they are from the baby boom
generation Steve Jobs and all those guys
so this is you know this is their Jesus
so they present the band as their Jesus
and just eventually it's just inevitable
that it's going to
annoy the generations after and not to
mention because we weren't born when
they were putting out albums it's
impossible for us to see how far ahead
of their [ __ ] time they were you know
and that's something I also see in
comedy where I've actually gotten emails
from people going what's the big deal
with Richard Pryor you know 35 years of
people ripping off his [ __ ] they've
actually made you know some of his stuff
you know that after 35 years people
finally caught up with them you know so
or like an athletic thing somebody sent
me a [ __ ] email this week was talking
about that that running back on
Cleveland remember that guy was talking
about who has the face mask makes him
look like the front of a Dodge Ram
pickup truck someone was saying they
thought Jim Brown of the Cleveland
Browns was overrated and that they're so
sick of hearing about this guy that if
this [ __ ] white dude played back in
that era with those skinny people who
played football he would have run all
over him which a lot of people say [ __ ]
like that and it's complete [ __ ]
because is if he played back then look
if you want to stick him in a time
machine yeah he would run all over those
guys but that doesn't mean he's better
you know what I mean that's like okay I
have a big test on Tuesday the me on
Friday will go back in time after I've
taken the [ __ ] test and then I'll
know all the goddamn answers that's what
it's like if you take today's athletes
and you put them back then what you have
to do is just say okay if you take that
guy and you had him born the same year
Jim Brown was born
you know he'd still be what he is today
because of the nutrition the the level
of just intelligence about sports and
what is possible at that moment the
workout equipment and all of that but
you know obviously if you take a [ __ ]
guy you know what the big flaw on that
is that kid today is not the Jim Brown
of this era or any [ __ ] era you know
and if you took Jim Brown from back in
the day you had him born in 1980 instead
of 1940 whenever the [ __ ] this guy was
born and he had access to all this all
this information about nutrition sports
science and all that he would have been
much bigger than he was he still would
have [ __ ] dominated all right so
that's one of those sports arguments
that they that that people have would
like to talk about Kobe Bryant because
they see Kobe doing everything that
Jordan has already done they they equate
it therefore he's as good as Jordan and
they forget the fact that no one had
ever done that [ __ ] until Jordan Jordan
changed the game all right same thing
with the [ __ ] Beatles the Beatles
were so [ __ ] far ahead of everybody
but now it's it's 40 almost 50 [ __ ]
years later yeah now you're gonna look
back on it after everybody's ripped him
off is gonna be like dude what the [ __ ]
was the big deal alright so there's that
and then the last thing is I'm sick of
people throwing old people out in the
[ __ ] yard you know like they're your
old iPod speakers yeah there's a loose
wire [ __ ] him he's out the goddamn door
I think it's [ __ ] all right I like
old people
even that [ __ ] [ __ ] downstairs I
like them I respect them and you what it
is is you look at them and you see that
dyed hair and you see their saggy man
boobs right yeah wrinkled up Toshi's
right so you equate that with their
level of intelligence rather
then this [ __ ] guy has walked this
planet for 65 75 85 [ __ ] years and
you know what's that expression a bunch
of things change they stay the same
stitch in time saves nine what other
[ __ ] I remember expressions whatever
you know this guy's seen everything that
you're about ready to see he's already
seen it okay he didn't have a [ __ ]
iPod who gives a [ __ ] alright my [ __ ] is
still a [ __ ]
alright some things don't [ __ ] change
and this guy has this whole wealth of
knowledge they his a guy's been playing
live gigs for 50 something [ __ ] years
alright he can still physically play why
wouldn't you want to go see him you know
with all his [ __ ] experience you know
yeah I mean I could see if he was
jumping off the piano trying to do
splits and touch his [ __ ] toes and
then he came down and blew out his knee
and they had to give him [ __ ] a
Geritol rub right on his blown out knee
then yeah you know what I mean but like
I don't like that whole [ __ ] it's
like it's like a corporate mentality why
your skins wrinkled up we have no you we
don't like looking at you beat it I
don't know I'd still go pay to see the
Rolling Stones
I would why wouldn't you why the [ __ ]
would those guys rent those guys give me
hope that I can sit there and drag my
ass out on a [ __ ] stage 80 years old
man what's up with Medicaid you know I
don't a cruise ship but I do understand
what you're saying because I definitely
want to if I'm on stage in my 60s and
70s 60s is fine because I'm still gonna
be [ __ ] annoyed and want to be out
there but in my 70s if I'm still on
[ __ ] stage I want it to be because
because I'm not because I need the money
because I want to be out there all right
I remember Keith Richards saying like
someone's like what are you guys gonna
hang it up he's like never
I'm a musician this is what I do I will
do this in front of two people or
200,000 it's what the [ __ ] I do you want
me to put down my guitar
you know he is a great line in his book
where he talks about how much he loves
guitar I don't fade this last week Keith
Richards has his book called life it's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] and he talks about how
he loves guitar so much that to this day
like he opens a guitar case and just the
smell of a guitar he wants to crawl in
there and close the lid all right so if
you ask this guy to stop going out
playing live you might as well put a
bullet in his brain you're killing the
man okay so having said that let Paul
McCartney do his [ __ ] thing hasn't he
been through enough I mean that guy
truly found the love of his life all
right she [ __ ] dies then he he's in a
bad place like the [ __ ] Jets strength
coach he goes out he marries some
gold-digging [ __ ] with one leg you know
which was the classic [ __ ]
misdirection cuz I bet in the back of
his head he kept going you know I think
she's a [ __ ] go digger and then that
other place like dude she only has one
leg man stop being so mean right and
then he just gave in to that there you
go and you think if you tried to trip
her you stuck your knee out like maybe
there was a possibility that she's
athletic enough that her fake leg would
just fall off and she would just be able
to continue hopping down the sidelines
and make a play granted she get a
penalty if she if she ran out of bounds
on her own you know there's a question
for you this week
if that [ __ ] gold-digging [ __ ] with
the one leg if she ran down she had a
[ __ ] Dolphins uniform on right she
went to the islands and got her hair
braided by some dude in Jamaica right
and she comes flying down the sideline
if you stuck your knee out hit her fake
knee right knocked her [ __ ] leg off
why am i repeating what you just heard
everything I just said do you think that
she would have the ability running
full-speed all right what we'll we'll
adjust a little bit you tell her you're
gonna do it you tell are you gonna do it
your legs gonna [ __ ] pop off
no the fake one Jesus Christ we think
I'm an [ __ ] did you shut up your dumb
[ __ ] all right I'm gonna [ __ ] not
shut up I'm gonna knock your fake
[ __ ] leg off sweetheart when you're
running full-speed if you can keep your
balance all right we'll give you some
shiny [ __ ] your gold-digging [ __ ] do
you think she could do it that is my
question for you during the holiday
season doobie doobie Doo and we knock
off your fake leg you can't um all right
what else do we got here you guys want
some YouTube videos for the week okay
once again as great as the Black Crowes
were let's let's talk about some [ __ ]
music that I respect but I have to shut
it off every time I hear it and that is
basically The Melancholy
singer-songwriter put a gun in your
mouth early to mid 78
you know did I talk about this last week
I can't remember like Carole King saying
it's too late baby now it's too late but
we really did try to make it so that is
that has died and [ __ ] kill yourself
you douchebag however that [ __ ] it goes
that song James Taylor I see found I've
seen rain my [ __ ] friend died in a
plane crash and I always thought that
I'd see you once again Carly Simon
that's the way that that's the way I've
always heard it should be I'm telling
you right now don't ever listen to that
song on a rainy [ __ ] day if you put
that song in you have a 40% chance of
doing something really harmful to
yourself Joan Baez diamonds and rust you
know and I have the song if you ever one
of those songs ever comes on you're in a
car and you don't have control of the
radio and you just feel yourself getting
dragged down this bottomless pit I have
the song that is basically like that in
adrenaline injection to the heart like
in Pulp Fiction just put on Huey Lewis
hip to be square all right I can't take
100% credit for that me and young Joe
DeRosa
all right the teen idols sensation of
the Opie and Anthony program we're
taught was it was actually a segment
that we'd love to do on the uninformed
show that we do once every nine years at
this point we were talking about how
it's impossible to be depressed if you
listen to Huey Lewis in the news put on
hip to be square I challenge you not to
[ __ ] get a smile on your face it's
like trying to hold off a yawn you know
you can't do it it's impossible so I I
don't know I don't know why I'm bringing
this [ __ ] up but like I don't know what
it is about that music I respect it once
again getting back to the Black Crowes
thing because it's actually human beings
producing all the sounds that you're
hearing alright but
you know Jesus Christ already do those
people have any happy songs who's
another one
oh that that [ __ ] girls sings in the
false set off with a weird eyes Joni
Mitchell singing about a pave paid the
parking lot pay paradise turned it into
a parking lot
you don't know what you got till it's
gone all right Joanie I got it last week
was better Jesus Christ you [ __ ] you
know I don't know did I have it was
there and it was there a point that was
made there other than the fact that I
can't sing oh here's a music question
for this week if you guys also know
other than playing drums I [ __ ] around
in guitar and I recently bought ac/dc
flick of the switch another underrated
which I know I did last week
underrated ac/dc flick of the switch I
just want to know what tuning of those
people and
are they tuned down like half a step
because it's like I listen to the album
I shut it off then I go and I go to
figure it out
like let's take the first song for you
guitar players out there rising power
alright he's doing a pull off down to a
B chord right but are they tuned down
like half a step because last night I'm
sitting there in my Jam jams and I got
my guitar that I can't even [ __ ] play
and I'm like you know what I'm gonna
have a little geek moment by myself that
nobody can see I'm gonna put on my just
[ __ ] record I'm gonna play along to
this song cuz I figured it out
the malcom part and it sounded like [ __ ]
and I tried tuning down half-assed and I
just could not [ __ ] figure it out and
beyond the fact that I suck can somebody
help me out what are they doing there I
know it's not a drop D
up detuning dead cuz I know what that
sounds like that sounds like Satan is
your [ __ ] and you got you got some
errands for it for it to run I know what
that sounds like
and I challenge somebody come up with a
riff and drop D tuning that doesn't
[ __ ] rock it's just it's just it's
the [ __ ] right but does that tune down
half a step that I can't [ __ ] get
come on man you heard how I sing help me
out here help me out or I'm gonna
[ __ ] sing for the rest of this
podcast alright it's the holiday season
alright wait let's let's continue on
here oh I got my I tell you somebody
rear-ended my Prius you know what I mean
which really is like [ __ ] Boonton and
eight-year-old in the ass when you
really think about it and got it just
hard enough where I couldn't walk away
and be like I don't worry about it you
know my hatchback wasn't quite closing
correctly you know I mean wasn't quite
didn't quite work on the hatchback area
kind of like a girl with a big booty you
know what I mean there's always a little
bit of butt crack coming up always got a
tug you know that's how you can judge if
you see a girl with a nice ass whether
or not she's a [ __ ] or not if she's
constantly trying to adjust her jeans
and pull them up so her ass crack isn't
coming out of the back of her pants
that's a good girl that's one you can
take home to mom just make sure if she
wears a dress but if she's just standing
there with like an inch-and-a-half
coming out she doesn't give a [ __ ] I
can't even say that she's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but either that or she's just
accepted who she is and for some reason
that they don't make jeans for girls
like that alright that's one of those
references that it just was such a
visual to me that I completely forgot
what the [ __ ] I was talking about let's
go back we talking about talking about
guitar who gives a [ __ ] oh let's talk
about my car so anyway so I'm getting it
fixed this week and so I went down to
the rental car place
it was a usual I go down there and I
asked for a [ __ ]
an economy car you know I don't give a
[ __ ] I really have no pride when it
comes to cars even though I [ __ ] love
them I don't give a [ __ ] I'm just so
into not having debt that I'm a little
miser so I get to sack on then they go
well the economy car isn't quite ready
we could give you a free upgrade to this
four-door [ __ ] pickup and then it
just became my you know even that
outweighs my miserly ways is I don't
like waiting
I refuse to wait so I go yeah [ __ ] it
I'll take it and then immediately my
girl is just like why did you get that I
can't drive that it's so big I'm like we
only got until Monday [ __ ] relax plus
we got to get to Christmas tree this
weekend right well you know dad if you
wonder how I did that that was not some
Phil Spector's [ __ ] that's called just
you just spin it around 360 away from
your mouth back around you like that
it's a new recording process I just
invented so anyways I go yeah we got to
go get the Christmas tree so for the
last two years I have to admit something
to you people all right I have been
going down to get these [ __ ]
Christmas trees and I have been getting
the traditional Christmas tree and we
all know what it looks like all right it
looks like someone on The Biggest Loser
about four weeks in that's what a
Christmas tree suppose about that full
you know but
other Christmas trees that I noticed not
the scrawny ones but they are minimalist
Christmas trees where you can see the
entire trunk and it's like
they still have the branches but there
it's very like symmetrical it looks
[ __ ] cool as hell
clean-looking Christmas tree right it
looks like one of those trees and like
the dr. Seuss books you know so I go you
know what [ __ ] this I'm gonna get
something different I like this tree it
looks [ __ ] cool I think the ornaments
are gonna hang off it much better as if
you know when you get one of those full
trees you know this yeah it's just it's
a [ __ ] pain in the ass and then the
end of the end of the goddamn you know
Christmas season if you're not a dick
and you just don't throw it out the side
of your car like a [ __ ] some you know
some piece of degenerate gambler that
owed your money I said have it by
Tuesday and then you just throw it out
the [ __ ] car right if you actually do
it the right way and you just sign up
it's a pain in the ass and makes it
unbelievable mess this thing you know
it's like it's like you ever walk into
like like when I'm out with with the
Whitney and we go out to one of her
clothing stores and if it's like a
corporate place the place is just
jam-packed with [ __ ] but if it's like
privately-owned they go out and they buy
these individual pieces they'll buy a
couple of sizes of each things that they
like and you go in there you pray to God
that they have your size and it's and
you go in and it's very minimalist
that's the sort of Christmas tree that I
bought and you know me as a fashionista
so I thought she would like it so I
bring this Christmas tree in and the
second she looks at it because I think
she's gonna be like you know like I live
she just have like techno music on like
I'm so far into the [ __ ] future here
the second she looks at it all my
confidence just drains out the bottom of
my shoes and she I go yeah this is the
Christmas tree and she goes oh yeah it
goes where's the rest of it I'm like no
no that's the style that's the style
that's supposed to look like that I go
doesn't it cool I mean it looks like one
of those trees and dr. Seuss she goes
yeah she goes I think it looks more like
that that Christmas tree and that
Charlie Brown carts now I feel like an
ass
so because I love the verbal abuse that
you guys give me every [ __ ] week I'm
actually gonna be dumb enough to send a
picture of my Christmas tree now granted
it's naked it's not all dressed up it's
not all dolled up all right it's like
Charlie's thoron and that stupid movie
monster that rather than chastising her
from being a murderous [ __ ] they
actually made a movie that said maybe
guys ought to look at themselves and
treat [ __ ] a little bit better before
they go and start killing you after a
[ __ ]
wasn't that the message of the movie
that's a message I got so anyways it
doesn't have any makeup on which I think
should automatically give it a Golden
Globe for being that courageous it was
so brave it was such a brave performance
just take a look at the Christmas tree
tell me what you think I think it looks
[ __ ] badass I love it I [ __ ] love
it and I stand by it
you know I'm breaking a little tradition
here so go on the MN podcast.com take a
look at my Christmas tree we'll have a
whole section where you can leave your
goddamn comments about what a [ __ ] you
think I am or maybe actually like and
along with that you can also look at
these YouTube videos the YouTube videos
are the weak people I just felt like I
should have had a theme some theme music
right there at some point at some point
I'm gonna have them make enough money in
this [ __ ] business I'm gonna make a
little studio and I'm gonna have all
those little sound effects like a real
radio show like anthe own Opie and
Anthony you know he's got all those
little buttons he pushes and ope he's
got all his little buttons that they
push you know those button pushing son
of a [ __ ] I want to be one too I have
dreams and when I do I'll have a little
[ __ ] theme music here but until then
you'll just sit there and listen to the
awful silence alright YouTube videos of
the week that you can watch on the mmm
podcast calm the official
fan webpage whatever the [ __ ] you call
it of the Monday morning podcasts
alright YouTube video this is one of my
favorite ones if people puking makes you
sick please don't watch this but you
know the great thing of watching a
videotape of somebody puking is you
don't have to smell it so you can just
enjoy the hilarity that it is you know
what I mean
it's like that [ __ ] that people they
stayed the vaporizer with weed you know
where it gets rid of everything all the
toxins it just keeps the [ __ ] that gets
you high this is this is the vaporizer
version of watching somebody puke watch
this video this is this is such a this
video literally made me cry laughing
epic beer pong puke it's just it's got
it all the the the volume of puke the
noises kids making when he's puking and
then the [ __ ] good-natured attitude
that this dude has he actually he has
poise while puking I think Mark Sanchez
could learn a little something about
this you know little poise under fire by
the way one of their offensive linemen
got hurt now watch him run for his
[ __ ] life alright this game managing
son of a [ __ ] alright alright YouTube
video another one this one is just so
[ __ ] creepy I love this I want to go
on a date with this woman it's called
the best model in the world and I'm sure
a lot of you guys have already seen this
and I'm sure tosh point-o has already
put it up but it's the best model in the
world hand model and is this woman
talking about being a hand model and for
a lot of people it's what she says but
for me it's the way she just keeps
stroking her hands I don't know what
she's doing but it is so [ __ ] creepy
I want to go on a date with her I want
to take her out to dinner have her
sitting across from me as I tell her
about how many brothers and sisters I
have and might hopes and dreams in life
as she sits there nodding just stroking
her hands and that crib would just it
would really I know I don't know call me
a [ __ ] psycho
but I would really love to just have
that experience it's on my bucket list
did I spell this right the next one is
cami secret parody boob apron you know
that thing that commercial they have out
there where women with the big titties
and you know their boobs always falling
out of their shirt but they don't like
wearing something underneath it to
alleviate the problem so they created
this little napkin that hooks onto your
bra straps first of all let's pause and
just say how [ __ ] brilliant an idea
that is as far as just making a million
dollars you know this chicks out there
who just have you know
efficient boobs let's try to think about
nice way of saying small boobs
comparable capable titties right they're
still gonna buy them just because I like
having different colors and sometimes I
don't want to wear a shirt and then
those other girls who lie to themselves
about how big their boobs are and for
some reason they've they buy a d-cup bra
you know when they got b-cup titties i
don't know why they do that kind of like
the guy who goes in and buys the Magnum
condom and then it slips off and he
becomes a [ __ ] father for the ninth
time yeah just watch that it's a parody
of that and this next one all I have is
a website but my my web guy is
definitely gonna have it up if you want
to watch a video of somebody who's about
ready to get arrested by the FBI watch
this video this guy took one of those
you know as those nerds who rather than
going out and getting a pilot license
they go down to an open field and they
just fly like a fake plane around
a model airplane motorized there it is
motorized playing around this guy put a
camera on it and he flew around the New
York City skyline oh yeah I'm sure this
guy isn't gonna get in trouble at all
least they had the brains to blur out
their faces but the dude is talking on
the video you can hear his voice think
they're gonna get caught some [ __ ]
gonna recognize his voice that he went
to high school with you know by the way
people if you do something illegal if
you're gonna be dumb enough to videotape
it don't put it on [ __ ] YouTube and
of all the [ __ ] cities to do it to I
mean it's definitely the footage is
[ __ ] cool but this guy buzzes the
Statue of Liberty with this model
[ __ ] airplane and considering the
military has those drones that can fly
around and just vaporize people it's
probably not a good idea to have one of
those flying around I'm gonna go out on
a limb so I look for that news everybody
these guys getting arrested in the next
couple of weeks okay we also have the
YouTube video of the the Jets strength
coach tripping the dolphin if you just
want to watch that and just watch that
with my psychoanalysis
my psycho psychoanalysis of that guy
is that it I think that's it those are
the YouTube videos of the weekend what
are we up to here at this point oh by
golly will you look at that 53 [ __ ]
minutes um I know what I need to do I
need to hype my last stand-up gig my
last official one of the official one of
the year I am gonna be at The Improv out
here in Brea California beginning this
Thursday and I'm can conclude on Sunday
and it's gonna be was that December 16th
17th 18th and 19th and I got to tell you
my new hour is really happy with where
it's at so I figured something out
somewhere during Seattle right through
the Cobbs gig in San Francisco and I'm
really excited I'm really excited to go
out there so uh you know come on out and
see me how about some Latino people huh
trying to break into this market out
here I I don't I don't know how to get
in touch with you guys you know I
started doing that rosetta stone [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I quit it
you know I really want to learn how to
speak Spanish and I'm realizing that if
it did a little bit of rosetta stone and
I just had somebody who spoke Spanish or
Mexican whatever the [ __ ] it is you call
it not trying to offend anybody I want
to know how to do it I think it's
[ __ ] I don't know it's a cool
language I want to learn how to say it
then I can talk to some Spanish women
who the [ __ ] at my kid all right so
that's it I'm gonna be there this
Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday all
right if you can't make it there and
you're in the San Francisco area I'm
telling you go see the Black Crows go
see them cuz I think they're gonna take
a little bit of a break after this tour
from what I've heard you know it just
fits into my hole don't go to the
automated checkouts don't go to see
these [ __ ] auto-tune jackasses go go
see the real [ __ ] deal all right
there I'm done with that [ __ ] and with
that is that the podcast for this week
I'm coming up a little short all of a
sudden I'm running out of gas you know
what it is I'm in I'm in my vacation
mode already and I'm in a silly [ __ ]
mood
I got my Christmas tree and I'm gonna be
singing out those [ __ ] holiday songs
this weekend on stage I just decided
that just for the podcast listeners and
I'm not even gonna explain why I'm doing
it I'll be telling joking this guy can
go [ __ ] himself it's the holiday season
Dobie Dobie do
all right who's kidding who am I gonna
keep repeating that [ __ ] joke is that
what I'm gonna do bill are you pulling
the Paul McCartney right now and you
don't know when to get off stage
according to that one [ __ ] listener I
think I am did I have any underrated
overrated underrated a four-door pickup
truck like I rented this week couldn't
believe how convenient was I went to go
see the Black Crowes I put me and four
other adults in that thing we went to go
see him and then the next day I got a I
got a [ __ ] Christmas tree in the back
standing upright you know it's funny
when I put it in the truck these three
people walked by walking down the street
one of them was some Mexican dude and he
in Spanish he said something and started
laughing and I was convinced he was
laughing at my tree you know another
reason why I would have loved to gotten
through the rosetta stone so I could
have said in Spanish um actually it's
not the Charlie Brown tree all right
Hector it's supposed to look like that
thank you very classiest very much just
to freak him up you know what I mean
cuz you know nobody thinks a white dude
could speak Spanish like how many times
did George Bush catch somebody saying
something [ __ ] up as he sat there in
his [ __ ] white elite [ __ ] Brown
penny loafers with no socks and his Pete
Carroll coaching pants right Jesus
Christ is the Seahawks get their [ __ ]
asses kicked this week or what I went to
and to this week everybody I finally
went 500 I got something for gamblers
out here that I know you're all going to
agree with
all right and Oh before I say you know
one of the reasons why I didn't do an
extra podcast because a lot of people
were asking me how come right after the
Jets game you didn't do a podcast making
fun of the Jets that's because I didn't
I didn't believe in our defense and I
thought it we had a really good chance
of not you know if losing that game by a
couple of points just because you know
when you let up twenty four to thirty
points that's what you know that's
definitely a possibility and I just
thought it would have been [ __ ] if I
came yeah you know what the [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] lost that's also why I kind of
took it easy on you this week what you
probably don't think I did but hey I did
defend your [ __ ] strength and
conditioning coach didn't I well alright
then
why did I just talk about that and I
can't remember what I was talking about
here's one for the gamblers out there so
I took the Eagles last night
alright given three and a half against
the Cowboys had they won I would have
gone three and one which I desperately
needed instead you know and they drive
down right down the [ __ ] field
alright they're down by three points and
they can kick a field goal and win the
bet
but because it doesn't matter they just
want to win the game they take a knee
and they run out the [ __ ] clock and
this is a rule that I think the NFL
should do you know subtly without
letting the public know because they
really can't line up with gamblers and
anything I really think that is in a
sign of solidarity for the regular Joe
out there who actually had the balls to
put money so believed in your [ __ ]
team if you put money on your [ __ ]
team and you have a chance to cover the
spread
and the final [ __ ] seconds you should
goddamn it you should do it and ev'ry
kicked a field goal you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I needed three in one I needed that
so [ __ ] bad so now I'm two went to I
can't pick a game to save my [ __ ]
life you know what's funny was I took
Tampa this week Tampa in Atlanta had
been my go-to teams and I did for some
reason Carolina has been a little Jekyll
and Hyde so I the game scared me it's a
divisional game I just didn't [ __ ]
like it I stayed away and I went with
the ramps because the Saints have been
Jekyll and Hyde and I wasn't buying into
this Oh
here they come [ __ ] that they've been
doing the last couple weeks and Sam
Bradford has been showing that he can
play at that level you know 100% wrong
on that game I can tell you this right
now to save yourself a [ __ ] ulcer
when the team you bet on throws a pick
six I don't give a [ __ ] if it's in the
first quarter shut the game off it's
over
it's a goddamn fourteen point turnaround
all right whatever
I've bitched moaned and complained
enough we're coming right up on an hour
I think that's a good that's a good
that's a good number isn't it that's it
god bless all you hope you enjoyed the
podcast this week get out there go do
your Kwanzaa Christmas or Hanukkah is it
over yet
I saw a couple people driving around
with menorahs on top of the car's not
even bullshitting
I thought only idiots did that with
Christmas trees are they mocking the
idiocy of Christians or they like we can
be dumb too you know like how women do
how come only you guys get to box and
have brain damage we want to do it too
you know why are women so convinced that
everything guys do is so [ __ ] worthy
of getting involved into you know it
dumb just sit back and think a minute
just sit back and think a minute I want
to join the workforce rather than
sitting around hanging out with cute
little kids I know it's a job what the
[ __ ] wrong with you
would that be awesome as a guy just
think about that right now
if the roles were reversed you know and
you had the option of just marrying some
rich broad who just go out there and
just take care of you you know you got
to do is just keep the house clean and
make a meatloaf a couple times a week
you can just tap out you know I'm not
saying you have to do that
but there's a lot of us out there who
would I do that for a couple I think
I'll be into [ __ ] stay-at-home dad
for a couple years and just chill the
[ __ ] out right
get an incredible shape so sick all
those broads out there talk well I got
oh I understand what they're out of
shape cuz they had to carry the baby but
if you're a guy
there's no [ __ ] reason why you can't
be in shape you didn't have to carry
that kid around you know you got all day
long to work out oh my god
we'll be the [ __ ] I know you thinking
all these kids they never [ __ ] go to
sleep yeah they do they take a nap every
[ __ ] you can nap with them you can
figure out a time you can go out and go
buy all kinds of healthy food and then
just chill out I would get the [ __ ]
NFL package I would just whined to my
rich wife in just because I would you
you know do like the you know they do
the little girl thing when they want
something why don't I just draw baby you
buy it for me I'd do that with the NFL
package why'd you you know just making a
roux easier when the kids are screaming
all right and I would [ __ ] tape every
goddamn game it would be my mission
every week that I was gonna watch all 16
NFL games or whatever the [ __ ] they have
cup people that by weeks 14 games
whatever the [ __ ] it is and I would sit
there like a [ __ ] defensive
coordinator who was waiting for the
phone to ring you know and was gonna get
picked up or some [ __ ] and I would just
I would watch all of those games and I
would get a gate I get a a padded
[ __ ] playroom where the kids couldn't
hurt themselves and I just [ __ ] get a
gate where they couldn't get out and I
just stick them in there all day and
play amongst ourselves and then I would
just watch all these games every once in
a while I would just throw food in there
like they were like you know animals at
the zoo you know rather than making
three sandwiches I'd make one big one
and I just throw it in the middle and
then just film it like the Discovery
Channel you know with the pecking order
like the the most dominant male lion
gets to eat first then all the other
ones are sitting there you know growling
and [ __ ] waiting to see when when the
biggest one is full when they can go in
I think I'd like that alright that's it
that's the podcast for this week please
help me out I want to know about that
one-legged gold-digging [ __ ] running
down the sideline if she could keep
going I want to know what tuning ac/dc
is using on the flick of the switch
album particularly
house is on fire in rising power and
it'll be funny if it's standard tuning
my ear is just that bad and what's the
last thing was there anything else I
know I [ __ ] asked you something else
I don't [ __ ] know what all right
that's the podcast for this week have a
great week hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
you